Let's look at the answer
to our cache quiz.
These three are very similar
to the options we have
when we want to get
books from a library.
This is like going to the library every
time we need to look up something, and
clearly we don't want to do that.
Main memory is just like the library,
slow and very large.
So if we go to the main memory every
time, we're spending a lot of time just
waiting for
the main memory to respond with data.
Having the small memory inside the
processor core and bringing the stuff we
access there is the approach of
basically caching the memory locations.
And this is very similar to borrowing
the book from the library so that we can
use it for awhile while we're interested
in a topic and then return it.
And finally having a huge memory next
to our processor and then bringing
everything in there is solving some of
the problems of going to the main memory
because this memory is hopefully
somewhat closer to a processor.
But this memory is still going
to be large and thus very slow.
So this is very similar to just
building a library closer to home.
Yes, you are saving some
time on each access but
most of the time you spend
per access is still there
simply because it takes a while to
find data in such a large memory.
So caches are exploiting spacial and
temporal and locality.
And overcoming the problem of having
a slow and large main memory, just
like borrowing books from the library
is exploiting spacial and temporal
locality, and overcoming the problem
of accessing a huge library slowly.